yeah so what do you think of that
experiment the chinese room so uh i
think the difficulty is that uh
the uh it's a category mistake to think
that uh consciousness exists at that
level
so imagine you were trying to build an
artificial agent
that is uh conscious in the same way as
you and me are
we cannot do this with a physical system
right the physical system cannot be
conscious apparently
so you would have to simulate it you
have to make it as if
to pretend to be conscious
how would you do this you would you need
for instance to have qualia qualia are
the features of experience there are
things like colors and sounds and the
relationship between them and surfaces
and
the experience of information flowing
through space and being hindered their
pressure and
lightness and heaviness and so on right
and valence something feels good or bad
and good or bad means that it forces you
to leave that state or attracts you to
that state and so on and we all these
dimensions these feature dimensions we
can of course implement as basically
geometrical models that we can compute
with
formal systems of our choice so it's
there is technical difficulty in how to
get all these computations right but
there is nothing mysterious about how to
make a system that behaves as if it
would see colors right it's going to not
just measure the wavelengths but it's
going to generalize the wavelength in
such a way that it normalizes over
average are lighting conditions says for
instance red is something that passes as
red under arbitrary lighting conditions
on the surface of an object that is red
and that you generalize this over all
the red objects and then you also get
the associations to blood and uh the
flag of the working class and to roses
and love and heat right all the
rednesses are now one step
away from this abstraction of red that
can be translated as a feature dimension
as part of the simulated experience of a
virtual system
and so uh of course this experience is
not real there is not really any
physical system that experiences
anything it's only being represented as
if it was it's basically like a
multimedia story it's not written in
uh
words in a natural language or in a
logical language but it's written in
something like a machine learning
language
and then this model is being used to
drive the behavior of the agent it's a
control model that is being used to
inform what the system should learn
and how it should interact with the
environment
and as a result it produces new steps
that produces new model contents and
some of these model contents are for
instance sorts these are not real sorts
these are as if sorts which means there
are conceptual and linguistic and
idiotic and imagined configurations of
such features
that give rise to the next set of
features to the next set of thoughts and
experiences right again these are
virtual they're not real here the is
what if the system would feel something
what if it there was a person what if
there were social interactions that
would matter to the system what if that
would experience uh red in a way that
corresponds to heat and so on right so
you build all this into the system and
you let it drive behavior including
speech
and self reports and it gives rise to
the next set of things so this system
would be indistinguishable from us right
because it's also thinking the same
things now it's producing the same
thoughts and producing the same story
and it would have emotions and
experiences
it was experienced phenomena for the
same reason that a character in a novel
experiences it because it's being
written into the novel by the author in
our case the author is the mind
and i think the answer to the big
question how is it that we can be
conscious in the physical universe is we
are not in the physical universe that we
only exist in that story we only exist
in the dream that's written by the mind
so this is the the way it works is it's
virtual consciousness is virtual
and the experience of realness that we
have is not the realness of the physical
universe because the physical universe
doesn't feel like anything right reality
doesn't feel real
what feels real is only simulacrum only
a simulation can feel real
to a simulacrum realness itself not
reality is a simulated property
consciousness is a simulated property of
a simulated system a physical system
cannot be conscious only a simulation
can be conscious outside of the dream
there is nobody
so we're conscious because we're part of
the story that the brain tells itself
yes the only conscious inside of the
story
and we are inside we are characters in a
story that the brain is telling itself
and we can talk across stories so here
we are
right now here's where i'm having
trouble because if i write a lord of the
rings for example is frodo baggins
actually feeling something or is he just
scribbles on a paper just because it's a
story doesn't mean it has to have
experiences associated with it so so
why do we the question is what do you
mean by is right so uh
this is the story that sounds like it
sounds like bill clinton
it depends upon what the meaning of the
word is
yes yes though it has to do with the
question of uh what's being taken as the
uh
of of reality
uh i think that a reality that cannot be
experienced is very unsatisfying right
it's not the reality that most people
would refer to the experience of reality
is something that is virtual it's
something that's it's the experience of
the vr generated by your mind
right it's a virtual reality that you
inhabit as a non-player character
and the non-player character is
generated by the mind as well to
describe the interactions of the
organism with the world
right it's a story about what the
organism does in the words the best
story that the mind can come up with
and this story is being used to inform
the behavior of the organism
and you cannot break out of the story
that's why the story is real to you so
the thing is to uh to frodo
his feelings are real in the story to us
they're not because we see this from the
outside we see how this thing can be
constructed we can even change the story
if we have companion paper and can make
him feel something different
but uh to frodo himself it doesn't make
sense that his feelings are real to him
unless we write into the story that they
suddenly don't feel real to him anymore
right
give me a scenario where you can write
and make a
conscious
being from your writing of a story
do you just write frodo now feels so and
so and then frodo actually does feel so
and so so it doesn't work with natural
language you have to use a functional
language that is
it's basically not just uh giving rise
to a description of what photo is doing
but you need to have a functional
implementation of an agent in an
environment
right so you need to have something like
a representation of middle earth and you
need to have a control agent inside of
middle earth that is being controlled by
uh
frodo self
and frodo self is a model of what frodo
is
and it's a model of basically the
affordances of that agent and the state
of that agent that is driven by that
control model
and so
this control model is going to contain
thoughts
that are the result of produce
interaction with photo's environment and
the thoughts when photo is implemented
properly will reflect on the needs that
this agent has
and the needs are in the agent because
they're being programmed into it right
it behaves according to these needs and
if the model is adequate and is con
conforming to those needs then this
model is representing uh pleasure and
pain in such a way that voter would
describe them similar to the way that we
would describe pleasure in pain and he
would describe them as his thoughts
because that's the best
implementation of its control model that
photo's mind can come up with
so the language that is being used is
not a natural language is not english
words or something it's a functional
language it's a programming language in
a way
so can you then take that and stimulate
a small consciousness
let's because we mentioned that it's
extremely complex to do something like a
human at least at this
at least in 2020.
can we make a small conscious agent
i think that we can but uh if the agent
is too small it's very difficult to
ascribe an interesting type of
consciousness to it
and the biggest difficulty is if you
have a conscious system that is not able
to attend to anything meaningful that we
can relate to how can we say that it
tends to anything
and in a way the biggest unsolved
problem of artificial intelligence is
not consciousness it's uh understanding
and understanding means that we map
everything that we perceive
onto a unified model of the universe
more or less unified but it's
we basically
explain something by creating a
relationship to a unified meaning and
the unified meaning is our model of the
world
and everything that we perceive we are
able to integrate into this model of the
world and this is something that our ai
systems are so far incapable of doing
and i think we are getting there but uh
yeah